[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
a guilty plea for a grandfather who
admitted his granddaughter's death
falling from a cruise ship was a
criminal act plus
prosecutors plan their strategy after
authorities arrest
more than 70 people for celebrating on
la lakers victory
also newly released video of george
floyd's 2019 arrest
as defense attorneys representing his
alleged killers make a new request
of their own and reform may be on the
way in yet another community
troubled by the police shooting of
briana taylor law and crime daily covers
court cases from coast to coast
and welcome everybody to law and crime
daily i'm aaron keller along with brian
buckmeyer and terry austin we begin with
a plea deal for a grandfather in the
heartbreaking death of a little girl
prosecutors say salvatore anello dropped
his 18 month old granddaughter from an
open cruise ship window in puerto rico
chloe wygand died from the 150-foot fall
anello is agreeing to plead guilty to
negligent homicide months after saying
he would do so
to try to help end part of this
nightmare for his family the deal allows
him to avoid jail time and serve
probation
in his home state of indiana according
to testimony from the family anello
helped raise the little girl who died
he claims he held her up to the window
thinking the glass would hold her
the window was in fact open an attorney
for the victim's parents released a
statement saying in part
this decision was an incredibly
difficult one for sam and the family
but because the plea agreement includes
no jail time and no admission of fats
it was decided the plea deal is in the
best interest of the family
so that they can close this horrible
chapter and turn their focus to mourning
chloe and fighting for cruise passenger
safety
this story however doesn't end with the
criminal case terry austin can tell us
about an ongoing civil suit terry
erin the little girl's family filed a
wrongful death lawsuit against royal
caribbean
it's filed in federal court in miami the
cruise line has moved for the
lawsuit to actually be dismissed
releasing surveillance photos of the
incident they claim shozanello leaning
out of the open window for several
seconds
reaching down and lifting up chloe and
then holding her
out of the window for 34 seconds before
losing his grip
and dropping her 11 stories to her death
an attorney for royal caribbean wrote in
the motion to dismiss
anello's actions which no reasonable
person could have foreseen
were reckless and irresponsible and the
sole reason
why chloe is no longer with her parents
so terry this civil suit contains some
damaging accusations of its own as for
the criminal case though
is negligent homicide the right charge
here
it doesn't seem like the right charge to
me aaron negligent homicide
is a criminal charge and it's brought
against someone who through criminal
negligence causes the death of another
but
here it seems more like a horrible
horrible accident
and a more appropriate charge might be
involuntary manslaughter which
lacks the element of intent so brian
anello is scheduled to be sentenced in
december in puerto rico do you think the
punishment fits the crime here
i do think it does because if you look
at the negligent homicide statute now as
it applies it's a fourth degree felony
there's no bottom end as to the lowest
amount of jail time it only goes up to
180 days
and i think the family is better suited
to have
this defendant face probation maybe
learn his lesson i don't think there's
much to learn here by sitting in jail
yeah i mean ultimately a no punishment
crime is what this is going to boil out
to be it sounds so
maybe this is the right crime for the
accusations here
i think it's i wouldn't say no
punishment because you still have that
homicide uh record on you and that is
going to affect you in some way no
punishment
would be that there's no jail time but
probation is a punishment in and of
itself
true i appreciate you clarifying that
brian let's move on now we've got
another story we want to talk about here
some fans celebrating the la lakers
championship
found themselves behind bars after the
big win so brian you're going to take us
through the facts and some of the legal
concerns here
yeah so please say a largely peaceful
celebration
of the win in downtown los angeles
turned violent
unconfrontational and destructive a
crowd of more than a thousand gathered
around the staples center after the game
some began throwing glass bottles
and rocks at the lapd now they arrested
76 people for vandalism assault on a
police officer
and failure to disperse two people were
injured by the police
eight officers were taken to the
hospital for medical treatment
so brian ultimately 76 fans arrested for
celebrating the local championship it's
a lot of cases in a city where
everybody's happy over the win how can
prosecutors move forward here
it really depends on the charges you're
going to see some of these charges like
fail to disperse
fall away they'll most likely be
dismissed vandalism it depends on the
extent of the vandalism
and the evidence against them they're
either going to be prosecuted for
low-level charges
or dismissed now the assault of the
officers depending on the level of those
injuries
they can see some pretty hefty charges
being weighed against them you had some
interesting concerns about
trying to prosecute one of the specific
cases
yeah so we actually saw some some
information that an individual who said
f kobe bryant was actually assaulted as
pretty much a gang assault
uh of a number by a number of kobe fans
i think the prosecution's gonna have a
hard time
finding witnesses in la to testify
against him
and also find a jury to find them guilty
this might be the first time we see a
prosecutor ask
to change the venue yeah i mean
everybody there loves kobe bryant and
many other people outside of l.a love
kobe bryant he's a very famous man
so uh that'll be an interesting one to
see uh go to trial assuming it gets that
far
brian appreciate the update there and
still ahead on law and crime daily a
foiled plot to overthrow the government
why the fbi says not one but
two governors were the targets and later
on new video released in the george
floyd case
it's the defense for four ex-cops who
mostly want you to
see and to be able to use the video
you're seeing right here
[Music]
a 14th person has been charged in the
alleged domestic terrorism plot to
kidnap the governor of michigan
brian higgins is being accused of being
part of a rogue militia group plotting
to overthrow the government and take
governor gretchen whitmer from her
vacation home
michigan's attorney general says some of
the defendants participated in
demonstrations at the state capitol
the indictment comes as we learn more
about the plot unraveled by a
confidential informant
and an undercover agent the defendants
are also accused of plotting to kidnap
virginia governor ralph northam
an fbi agent testified the men discussed
taking out
sitting governors due to their
coronavirus related lockdown orders
a person who attended a june meeting
with the men in ohio came forward to
authorities with concerns over potential
violence
undercover agents embedded with the
group for months
tracking their encrypted communication
and clandestine recordings
attorneys representing several of the
former police officers accused of
playing a role in the alleged murder of
george floyd are again complaining
of stalking and harassment as they leave
the courthouse
the attorneys are renewing complaints
which date back to a similar hearing in
september
to one held this week this time they're
asking a judge to admit into evidence a
video
which shows the alleged stalking and
harassment the attorneys for the
ex-officers say the
incidents prove the trial should be
moved out of the area
and the judge overseeing the case also
authorized the release of victim george
floyd's 2019
arrest by police the video shows an
officer approaching floyd who was seated
in a car
asking him to undo his seatbelt and
floyd said he feared being shot
in the words of the officers he kept
moving his hands in a way which
made them nervous here's some of the
nearly 17-minute long recordings
keep your hands where i could conceal
them
okay put them up on the dash put them on
the dash
i'm not gonna shoot you put your hands
on the dash
put your hands on the dash the last time
i'm going to tell you that it's simple
he keeps moving his hands around
he won't listen to what i have to say
[Music]
you're not going to get beat up or
nothing if you just follow
[Applause]
i know you're a big man you're gonna
have to slide in
floyd admitted to taking as many as
eight narcotic painkillers and said he
was struggling with addiction
officers got him to a hospital where
crews were concerned about his blood
pressure
according to records cited about this
particular incident
from the washington post and coming up
on law on crime daily another community
pushes for reform because of the police
killing of brianna taylor plus
new perspective on attempts by a young
man who videotaped the killing of his
girlfriend
to take back his guilty plea
[Music]
an upstate new york judge is weighing
whether to allow a defendant to take
back his guilty plea after prosecutors
say he video recorded
a murder and posted it online victim
bianca devins was stabbed to death in
july last year at age 17.
prosecutors say brandon clark then 21
uploaded
images of himself killing devins which
then spread online
clark pleaded guilty but now claims his
attorney misled him into thinking he
could change his plea
even after a judge accepted it one of
clark's attorneys testified that clark
wanted to plead guilty in part because
a trial wouldn't allow him to control
the narrative
of what happened local crime and courts
reporter jolene ferris has been covering
the case i spoke with her recently
about how the community and the victims
family is handling the developments we
just talked about
and whether she thinks a trial could be
ordered
he was pretty stoic i would call him
unflappable
in spite of some questions that were
probably designed
in substance and perhaps also delivery
maybe to bait him or get him going a
little
you know like well where did you go to
law school when he was citing his own
legal research regarding the matter but
he was pretty
unflappable pretty stoic and even keeled
what were people in the gallery saying
what was the reaction from the victim's
family for instance
well they were there they've been there
every day and they will be there every
day but they're very calm
and they say they're not going to harbor
hate in their heart over this
they just want to see justice done for
their daughter and granddaughter her
grandfather's been
sort of the family spokesperson her
mother was there as well
but um they're just really hanging their
hopes on the judge
refusing to give brandon clark
his trial refusing to let him withdraw
his plea and
of course we know the judge said he'll
have a written decision by october 30th
he wants everyone back in court november
10th
at which time he'll either sentence him
or schedule further matters
any sense of where the judge is going to
go with this if i had to hazard a guess
i would think he would probably give him
a new trial but that's just me
you know guessing no one wants to be
overturned on appeal and you know
let it be heard how do people react to
this case
locally they spoke of two videos
yesterday
not only of you know the crime itself
but a video taken as she lay dying so
just you know victim bianca devin's
grandfather too keeps saying you know
what could be in your heart for someone
to
not only commit the act but want to
record it
and show it to family and then there are
people that
continue to push this at the family so
they're being re-victimized every time
someone sends them another copy of this
video that's out there on the internet
yeah and you know the big thing is too
if this does go to trial obviously
they're going to have to sit through it
and see it possibly in a room with
strangers again and they've already said
they'll be there every step of the way
so
you know that's another thing sort of
hanging over everyone's head is having
to see this
horrifically graphic video in court
so brian there are many twists and turns
to this case and clark's attorneys
testified at the recent hearing about
whether the police should be allowed to
stand or whether it should be withdrawn
that they did everything properly but
clark claims his attorneys told him that
he could change his plea basically
even after the judge accepted it does
that make any sense to you whatsoever
what clerk is saying that his attorney
told him doesn't make any sense
and i actually think he's not going to
get a new trial i believe that the judge
is insulated in the fact that the judge
went through the pr the plea allocation
with him and he understood it there
and also to break attorney-client
privilege is
huge and so for the attorney to testify
in the way that he did so long as he's
found incredible
i think that the judge has something to
hang their hat on yeah i mean it's
important to note that the defendant
agreed to waive the privilege basically
because the defendant testified as well
and said my attorney did everything
incorrectly
terry we've talked about this case a lot
but the re-victimization of the family
is leading them to try to push for
changes to the laws in new york state
yeah and it's a great bill because what
it'll do it'll hold big social media
companies
accountable companies like facebook and
instagram
and they'll be accountable for the
spread of graphic content like we saw
here but the other great thing is the
bill empowers the ftc
and the attorney general to enforce the
requirements and
impose penalties on these companies so i
think there'll be some accountability
there
oftentimes reform comes out of tragedy
and that may be the case here
terry and brian appreciate the insight
there when we come back reform movements
are popping up in the wake of the police
shooting of briana taylor as well
a judge and a prosecutor weigh in on a
council member's plans
to ban no knock warrants in their
community we'll be right back with that
we've talked before on this broadcast
about pushes for reform in the state of
kentucky after the police shooting of
briana taylor
but other people in other places are
also asking whether a ban on no knock
warrants might avoid tragedy in their
own communities
taylor was killed when police executed a
warrant written as a no knock warrant
taylor's boyfriend says he's a million
percent sure that nobody identified
themselves
though the police say they did announce
their presence the boyfriend kenneth
walker said he grabbed his gun when he
heard the noise and
he legally owned that gun thinking an
intruder was trying to break in he
admits firing a shot
gunfire then erupted and police shot and
killed brianna taylor
a city council member in cincinnati ohio
now wants to ban no knock warrants in
his city but
it's not up to him or his fellow council
members they can only tell the city
manager that
they want this ban and it's up to the
city manager to implement it
i've done a lot of research i talked to
a lot of national groups
and it's just my opinion that no knock
warrants put officers
uh civilians and unintended uh people
at risk there are officers who have been
killed
there are officers in bronze case that
were uh shot in the foot
uh in another case um a knurlock warrant
was issued and
a device went into like a not a bomb but
something that spread smoke
went into a baby's crib and the baby had
to be put into a mentally medically
induced coma
so my motion we're going to revise my
motion it's going to be broader than
just banning no knock warrants there
will be exceptions for
kidnapping or human trafficking and it's
really going to talk and focus on
how raids are conducted so
we're going to we're going to make sure
that raids are conducted during the day
briana taylor the raid was conducted
after midnight they were in their bed
watching a movie
and so you don't expect police officers
to be barging in
after midnight when you've done nothing
wrong
that's just one view county prosecuting
attorney joe deters says
no knock warrants are rare and that the
city council should listen to experts
before legislating
i should note for you number one
they're an important tool for law
enforcement in some
cases but number two they are
very very rarely used for instance
we served probably over 2 000 search
warrants last year
and less than five were no knock
warrants
and less than two the less than three
were
executed that led to an arrest
right now the standard to the judge is a
good cause
and the attorney general wants to move
it to probable cause which is a little
bit more stringent
that there's a likelihood of crime's
been committed
and there's a likelihood that this is
the person who committed the crime
so in that respect um it will
toughen the ability to get them no
the city council should learn how to be
city councilman first
not cops they don't know what they're
doing
and i know it's well intended
that what they're trying to do but they
are not
experts in this field and they should be
relying on those experts
the presiding judge of the hamilton
county ohio court of common pleas
believe no knock warrants
may be necessary in some situations
i can appreciate people's concerns about
the no knock versus knock
and and i the one thing i would caution
everybody is
you shouldn't respond on an anecdotal
basis
and there's a lot to be said for leaving
those people who are
dealing with a situation namely law
enforcement and the particular judge
leaving them with the discretion to
determine whether or not it's
appropriate
to have a no knock rule these are rarely
done in hamilton county
and usually when they're done they're
done with tactical teams such as swat
and that kind of stuff so you've got
people that are expertly
um that are you know executing these
warrants
but for for a no knock rule you know
which you typically can envision would
be a circumstance where you've got a
confidential informant
who is in somebody's house who says that
you know can name the individuals that
were in the house
can say look they're heavily armed they
can check the criminal history and they
can realize that the
individual that they're after has a
significant criminal history
of violence whether it's felonious
assault or some
some other violent crime such as that
so terry the attorney general of ohio
believes the solution is to heighten the
standards the authorities need to meet
to secure a no knock warrant is that the
proper solution in your opinion or
should the reforms cut deeper into the
system such as the council member
suggests
you know i think that you could make an
argument that you could
raise the standards and limit the use of
these no knock warrants
but it would have to be extremely
limited i wouldn't want it to have
anything to do
with you know drugs or guns only if
someone is kidnapped
for instance would i want to go in there
without knocking so i think there's a
lot of danger behind
a no knock warrant and it's dangerous to
the police and it's dangerous to the
people behind that door
yeah so much debate about reform coming
out of the briana taylor case and
company in uh in counties i should say
across america so brian
uh what do you think should should they
just raise the standards should they get
rid of them completely because that's
the proposal
uh in briana taylor's home state if you
raise the standard and give
prosecutors officers and judges the
discretion to have no knock warrants or
not
they're going to have no knock warrants
raising the standard doesn't mean
anything
you get rid of them at the end of the
day it's safer for officers it's safer
for
the people inside as well the only
reason why you have no knock warrants is
to ensure that the contraband that's in
the home
isn't secreted away or destroyed and
that is not worth the life of the people
inside or the officers entering
yeah and oftentimes you know there's the
old saying in law school that the minute
you knock you hear a toilet flush
evidence disappears things like that and
that apparently is why we have them
that's one of the legal
theories behind them but so many people
saying get rid of them right now
thanks a lot for joining us here on law
and crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice
in america
[Music]
[Music]
you